Британські прем'єри - нещедрі на увагу до України.
Офіційний візит за 30 років був лише один - у 1996 році.
І от нині другий - на тлі загрози російського вторгнення
прем'єр-міністр Борис Джонсон відвідав Київ.
Заяви про підтримку України відбуваються на фоні внутрішнього
британського скандалу, головним героєм якого став саме Джонсон.
У Великобританії його звинувачують в організації та відвідуванні 16 вечірок
у той самий час, коли інші британці мали сидіти вдома через коронавірусні обмеження.
Тепер Скотланд-Ярд розслідує інциденти з вечірками, а Борис Джонсон
стрімко втрачає прихильність як серед звичайних британців,
так і серед однопартійців. Британські медіа вважають, що візит Джонсона до Києва
просто відволікає увагу від внутрішнього скандалу в Сполученому Королівстві.
На думку експерта аналітичного центру "Українська призма" Олександра Краєва,
Джонсон справді навмисне фокусується на питаннях України.
Просто візьмемо з вами останню промову Джонсона в парламенті,
коли йому опозиціонери закидали, що так, він вибачився, але він має понести кару
за ці вечірки ковідні і так далі. Майже цитата Джонсона: давайте не будемо
на це відволікатися, у нас є питання України. Це найбільш нагальне,
чим нам треба зайнятися, на чому нам треба сконцентруватися і так далі.
Натомість експерт з питань Східної і Центральної Європи Войцех Пшибильський вважає,
що підтримка Джонсоном України має набагато глибші причини,
ніж просто політичний піар.
Цей прем'єр - шоумен. Це без сумніву. Я не здивуюся, якщо він буде шукати увагу
і розпалювати суперечки через заяви, які він робив у Києві.
Але я хотів би підкреслити стратегічну глибину у цих відносинах.
Це не просто оборона Європи, це британські інвестиції в альянс для того,
щоб бути корисними для американських партнерів у Європі.
Тож цей візит та політичні інвестиції можна розглядати як бажання ЄС
у певних питаннях йти з нами в ногу.
Некоректно стверджувати, що скандал з вечірками - це основна причина,
чому уряд Британії зараз активно підтримує Україну,
вважає експерт із зовнішньої політики Сергій Солодкий. Навпаки, це може свідчити,
що попри внутрішні проблеми Сполучене Королівство
чітко визначило свої міжнародні пріоритети.
У британців завжди були аргументи, чому вони не могли в повній мірі
проявити себе в плані підтримки України. І тут зараз зворотня ситуація
- коли є внутрішні проблеми Британії, але вона за них не ховається цього разу.
Я би не став судити й оцінювати мотиви Бориса Джонсона.
Я би сказав так: дуже добре, що він цього разу, на відміну від попередників,
виявився вище внутрішніх скандалів і перипетій,
і надає належної уваги російській агресії, протидії агресії.
Справді, Британія від початку війни на Сході України активно підтримує Україну.
В першу чергу зброєю і спільними навчаннями.
На зустрічі у Києві Джонсон ще раз на цьому наголосив.
Ми робимо все можливо, щоб посилити спроможність України чинити опір.
Саме тому ми і надіслали 2 тисячі протитанкових ракетних систем.
І ми навчаємо військових в Україні.
У той самий день у МЗС України оголосили, що Британія, Польща та Україна
укладуть договір про тристороннє партнерство.
Деталі такого договору поки що не розголошують.
Попри це і українські, і міжнародні експерти схвально ставляться до такого союзу.
Британія і Польща регулярно допомагали Україні окремо. Альянс трьох країн
вважають кроком вперед у дипломатичних стосунках держав.
За словами Олександра Краєва, цей союз насамперед вигідний з практичних міркувань.
Наприклад, поставки зброї Британією та Польщею Україні будуть краще координовані,
а отже більш ефективні, якісні та з кращими програмами.
Подібні альянси також допомагають здобути вагоміший голос у вирішенні
політичних питань на міжнародній арені, вважає експерт.
Для цього альянсі є два напрямки - на Москву і на Брюссель.
Москва - очевидний наратив, тому що і для Британії, і для Польщі
Росія стала загрозою, а не викликом. Що стосується Брюсселя…
Україна в свою чергу... Ми рухаємося в Європу, але ми бачимо кволу,
іноді пасивну реакцію ЄС на певні виклики і неактивне бажання ЄС
у певних питаннях йти з нами в ногу.
Очевидно, що і цей напрямок в союзі буде втілений.
Наприклад, на двосторонньому рівні ми би не змогли розвинути діалог із Брюсселем
на такому ж рівні, як це зробимо в цьому союзі.
Сполучене Королівство більше не член ЄС, але один з великих акторів
на міжнародній арені. Водночас Великобританія та Польща - члени НАТО.
Деякі оглядачі вважають, що новий тристоронній союз буде зменшеною версією
НАТО для України. На думку Войцеха Пшибильського, таке порівняння перебільшене.
Проте трьохстороння угода все одно робить Україну ближчою до вступу
в інші великі західні союзи.
Будь-яка форма залучення України до союзів із західними країнами дуже важлива.
Це не єдиний, але один із важливих сигналів, коли майбутнє значною мірою
залежить від того, наскільки Україна готова інвестувати та не відставати
від західного партнерства з ЄС.
Так, цей крок важливий для подальшої інтеграції України.
Окрім надання озброєння та проведення спільних військових тренувань,
Лондон готується і до нового виду санкцій у разі вторгнення Росії.
А саме жорстких санкцій проти олігархів, близьких до Кремля.
Олександр Краєв прогнозує, що список підсанкційних осіб буде довгим
і включатиме не тільки олігархів, а і їхні родини, їхніх дітей.
Що це може за собою тягнути, що можна зробити - заморозка рахунків,
початок досудового слідства, початок фінмоніторингу. Всі олігархи,
які роблять такі справи, бояться фінмоніторингу британського.
Це просто найжахливіший кошмар для такого роду людей, тому що він точно все виявить.
І навіть такі базові речі, які все таки будуть проведені - це просто
заморозить життя для цих людей, їхніх сімей і дітей.
Сполучене Королівство стало одним з найпотужніших партнерів України
за останні роки. Підтримка Британії відчувається і в розбудові української армії,
і в сприянні реформам. Однак досі достовірно невідомо, чи не стане Україна
приводом для відведення уваги від внутрішніх проблем Британії.